today i want to talk about language and
history
[Music]
hi there steve goffin here today i want
to talk about
language and history uh
but if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe
you can click on the bell to get
notifications come and join me at link
where i learn languages so you know i've
been
embarked on this sort of
effort to learn uh the languages of the
middle east
uh to learn more about the history and
i'm amazed at what i'm discovering
uh and it's just so fascinating to
penetrate this world
and i just wanted to share with you
because i find it quite exciting so
so i had my arabic period and i did some
reading
and i have to do more reading about the
arab world and the history of
our people before islam after islam
and so forth but now i'm into my um
persian period but what's interesting
is that the history of iran so and of
course
now not only have i been listening to
the stories or the episodes the course
we have at link on the history of iran
i've also been listening to a course
that sahara did for us on the different
different ethnic groups in iran and of
course
it's very interesting because in iran of
course
whatever it is 80 of the population is
is uh
farsi people persians if you want
farsi people and whatever number 15 18
are i'm going to end up with more than
100 but it doesn't matter
are azeri turks and then we have
you know kurds and turkmens
and arabs and other sort of linguistic
groups
which are essentially persian so what's
interesting in all of this is
because i now start to read not only do
i hear
sahara describe the different sort of
other also armenians for example and who
are christian and there are some jews in
iran
but but she describes how these
different groups some are
on the border with sort of another
country that has more of the same
population which would be the case with
azeri's
which would be the case with kurds which
would be the case with arabs
obviously not the case with armenians
because the armenians are not
located near the border with armenia i'm
not even sure there is a border with
armenia
but so i read about that that she
provide that
you know i get the terminology and all
in the persian language
but then i read up in english and right
now for example there's a major
um you know conflict
in the border between azerbaijan
or even within azerbaijan and between
them and
armenia and different countries are
interfering iran
turkey russia u.s whatever
but what's interesting is i have this
big thick book on the history of modern
iran and it starts with the safavid
dynasty dynasty which was founded by
and i'm not entirely clear on this but
it was
founded by uh a person
ismail i think who who
was from this azerbaijan area
and depending on which source i read he
was either
an azerbaijani
therefore turk or he was a turkmen
but his forces were primarily turkmen
and so it was a group of people
from this region who were not iranians
who basically took over
iran after the country had been you know
in great disarray as a result of the
mongol invasions and so forth and so on
and so it's very interesting it's
it's kind of similar to say in china
where for the last thousand years of
their history they were
for a good part of the time dominated by
uh sort of peoples from inner asia
manchurians mongolians and stuff
and similarly in iran there were a
number of
dynasties that were founded by turkmens
or azeri's or
uzbeks or whatever i don't know enough
yet so so
that's in a sense fascinating and he
imposed the shia religion on the
iranians
uh very ruthlessly uh
but then it's interesting to see that
the azeri's
in terms of sort of the connection sort
of language versus
call it ethnicity dna
the kurds their language is related to
the iranian language family which
includes
baluchi and and pashto in in in pakistan
and afghanistan
and even the ascetians in southern
russia and
in disputed area in georgia so that's
that language group but
language doesn't necessarily match
genetics
so that the people in the caucasus even
the georgians
uh and it's a number of say
azeri iranians may share more dna with
georgians
than they do with persians depending on
where these persians come from
so there's this whole mixture and the
same is true for people who would now
say some syrians so so there's depending
on
when the language and how the language
is imposed on
people who were originally living there
the people that we identify by their
language
maybe that's all you can say about them
that this is their language and because
that's their language then they
identify a certain way but that doesn't
mean somehow that
genetically they are that group
i mean the same is true throughout
history when we talk about
celts or any other group we don't really
know if we're talking about
you know a unique tribe genetically
or whether we're talking about a group
of people who had a certain language
imposed on them for whatever historical
reason and who now
identify or maybe that same group called
celts has many languages
in fact in many cases they did so it's
very interesting
that that language gets us into history
and enables us to see you know certain
things
and enables us to discover that language
is only
one layer of identity
and historically these identity markers
have
changed so people might identify
primarily by their
religion here again iran there's a shia
relationship and then as i read these
books i learn more about
what shia shiism is
because i could never quite understand
why there was this difference between
the sunni and the shia
and i still don't but i'm getting closer
because another thing i found is
not only in language learning but in
everything we learn
we kind of have to cover the same ground
many many times before
things start to become clear it's not
because you read it
once say a grammar explanation or a
description
of what distinguishes a shia from a
sunni and the twelvers and
whatever you know all the stuff ali and
stuff
it doesn't make much of an impression
until you have come across it in
different contexts
and then it starts to become clear and
then when you hear about it in
say persian or in arabic it it it
resonates even more
so all i'm saying is as someone like
myself who's interested in history
engaging with the languages of an area
uh helps you explore all these
relationships
and that reminds me that while i'm in
persian now and occasionally i'll
refresh my arabic
i am going to get back to turkish
because the turks have had an amazing
influence
on the history of
you know the you know call it the whole
area from
from turkey to india uh the
turks were always out there ready to
come in and
beat up on the sedentary people and
impose their will so
essentially mughal india was a turkish
empire with persian-speaking bureaucrats
and the persians were always the sort of
the mandarins and the people who who
provided the bureaucracy and
the ministers i mean i'm exaggerating to
simplify but
that's kind of the impression and many
of the
dynasties in iran were started by
one form of turk or another
and they were always you know ready to
whether it be timur or whether it be
uh you know the safavids or or other
groups
uh so that whole complex of
relationships is something that
through my study of those languages i'm
gonna not only
learn about in those languages but i
will then be
encouraged stimulated to go and read up
about them
in say english or french where i you
know obviously can
you know read and get that information
faster but language and history in my
mind are
intimately connected anyway thanks for
listening bye for now